we talked earlier about Ryan Fitzpatrick
who comes in at number 28 on the Chris
Sims top 40 quarterback countdown and
Ryan Fitzpatrick if you haven't heard
went to Harvard and we we have fun with
that from time to time time it's the
modern-day Jerome Bettis is from Detroit
and and so today's draft is essentially
all of those dumb narratives that people
forget that insert line type thing that
we hear all the time the things we keep
having to deal with that just come up
over and over and over again that's the
best way I can explain it just tired
narratives that we get sick of dealing
with but also that make us smile a
little bit and the trivia question is
this Chris very simple since Ryan
Fitzpatrick if you haven't heard went to
Harvard true or false
no player from Harvard has been drafted
before the fourth round true or false
oh that's a really good one
trying to think there I feel like there
was one player I'm missing maybe I'm
going to say false it is true no player
has been drafted before fourth round two
players taken in round four both most
recently Cayuse chick now the 49ers and
some of the guys who have played who
went to Harvard and made it to the NFL
Matt Burke Cameron Breit Desmond Bryant
remember Pat McNally who was the punter
for the rebels back in the 70s a
surprising number of guys it's easy to
find it online there's a go crimson comm
page that has all of them a lot of guys
have made it from Harvard to the NFL
including Ryan Fitzpatrick all right
first one for me man there's a lot of
different ones I can do I'm gonna go
with X is a winner insert name is a
winner and it's typically a quarterback
is a winner right he's a winner
no his team wins now I'm always hesitant
to completely downplay the impact of
quarterbacks on wins and losses because
I do think that a quarterback can
inspire the teammates to come together
and perform at a higher level and that
there are things about the
quarterback that will enhance the
possibility of winning the game sure
right saying a guy is a winner it's a
tired narrative we get fined for it if
we say it on the show I'm hoping that I
don't get fine for using it as the first
pick in the draft no III it would have
been my number one pick that's what it
would have been it is it's a lazy take
he's a winner you know when people start
that you know you know me you've heard
me say it a lot through the draft
process we've we've crapped all over it
with like the John Elway Patrick mahomes
in college they weren't winners oh
somehow they happened I understand what
people mean by saying it but it just
doesn't reflect the the proper thing
there and and I can't even cannot stand
when people say it you know in the draft
process or something like that that's
where you constantly hear it and
sometimes you hear it from non quarter
about non quarterbacks to which I also
go
what like okay so whatever it's a team
sport it's the ultimate team sport but
for some reason when we start talking
about the team winning and losing we
like to break it down to one player and
then when that conversation is over we
go it's the ultimate team sport so that
makes no sense all right I don't know
have you ever heard this Tom Brady was
drafted in the sixth round he's got a
chip on his shoulder
did you know he's got a chip on the
shoulder he's still angry about it he's
waking up every day
that's one like you know again I think
yes we all know everybody on earth knows
Tom Brady was later that amazed I know I
know it is it's still amazing but I
still feel like when we watch a telecast
that announcers talk about it like hey
you might not have heard this yet but
Tom Brady was a six rounder and he still
plays with that you know so I get sick
of hearing that a little bit I do you
know and also my take on that is you
know Brady was allowed to workout and
train for the combine to maybe help
himself in the draft to be higher than a
six round draft pick now obviously
people miss evaluated and screwed it up
but I don't know it's just one of those
where it just feel like nobody can talk
about Tom Brady without bringing that
subject up well and and it is amazing
that it is still at the forefront of his
brain all these years later and he uses
it for motivation every single day even
though it happened 20 years ago next one
for me running backs don't get paid
enough you hear that from time to time
all that running backs don't get paid
enough my oh they don't get mad they get
paid exactly what the market bears
because the supply outweighs the demand
every major college program generates
every year a guy who can play running
back effectively at the NFL level if you
block for him if you teach him how to
hold on to the football and if you trust
him to pick up Blitzers and pass
protection he can make it at the NFL
level there's so many guys out there
goes to what we were talking about
earlier ohto Beckham junior his current
contract Christian McCaffrey and his you
can find a replacement for McCaffrey
cheaper younger not better but the gap
not so big right justify not embracing
the possibility of going with a younger
guy and just churning out a younger guy
every three or four years and then move
on to the next young guy at running back
because there are so many of them so
running backs get paid exactly what they
deserve the ones who are great are in
position to leverage more and they
should but for the most part the market
reflects the reality that there are a
lot of guys out there who play running
back and play it well and I remember Ben
Tate the former NFL running back said at
one point if I had to do it all over
again how to put the defensive back ya
know well you know I'm glad you just
said that because that's what I was just
about to say you know III think we're
already seeing a little change you know
of course a lot of these guys are
running backs because they were the
fastest most explosive guys on their
team growing up so the coaches and
Little League football and peewee
football just hey let's just toss into
that guy and let him run who cares if we
block anybody and then they end up
staying and running back forever but I
do think we're starting to see guys who
maybe we're running backs going you know
what the hell with running back in high
school I want to play receiver and go to
college as a receiver and we're seeing
more of those receivers and running back
type bodies in the NFL I think because
of that because of
all the things you said there they're
growing on trees it's a physically
demanding position so I'm with you that
was a good one all right here's another
one you know we're gonna go out there
and give 110 percent today a hundred and
ten percent not a hundred but this is
our top line but we're gonna find more
to just go ten percent more and it's
going to be more than our best effort
it's going to be a hundred and ten
percent we have our best effort but then
we got this extra ten percent that makes
the bestest effort okay the hundred and
ten percent effort that one kills me too
and more times than not I hear players
and coaches say it which is you know
hilarious
yeah and it's ridiculous because by
definition whatever your absolute best
is is 100 percent right next one for me
and and this is a college football pet
peeve this is a college football tired
narrative and it drives me crazy every
year when I see a college game
inevitably every game you watch you will
hear this phrase in relation to multiple
players on the field you'll see them on
Sundays next year this is it I feel bad
but but these guys who are college
football analysts think that they can
project which guys who are standing out
in today's game are gonna be definitely
the NFL next year know now I think it
makes watching game oh let's watch this
game we got some future NFL players here
no you don't for the most part you don't
at least it's not the guys that they're
pointing out oh you'll see him on
Sundays next year that just drives me
crazy it's one of the reasons why I I
mean I like college football when I have
time to watch it I'm usually traveling
on Saturdays but it drives me crazy I
want to throw my shoe into the TV every
time I write but you're I mean you watch
a big college football game you're right
you're gonna hear it probably
double-digit times when it's all said
done about you'll see them on Sunday so
good one there okay I think the one I
gotta go in here is you know I love this
when the announcer comes on and he's
talking into his mic and he's going you
know Team X is forty seven and one
when they're running back runs for a
hundred yards right that's the one that
drives me crazy too because I want to go
well no crap team X is 47 and one when
the running back runs for a hundred
yards because yes team X is whooping the
crap out of Team Z so thank you yes if
it were that easy or or the rushing
attempts one two when when team X gives
the ball to this running back 20-plus
times in a game they never lose yes well
in those games it's the same premises
they're dominating the line of scrimmage
they can keep giving the ball to the
running back who gets six yards at a
clip and that's why they can give it to
them plus 20 times because it's very
successful so that's one that I just
want to go you know what color is blue -
it's just Captain Obvious statement
there that drives me crazy at times or
is the case maybe what color is purple
it was the Mike Tyson and E ratio that's
what you immediately reminded me of the
idea that if Randy Moss gets the ball 40
percent of the time the Vikings win well
yeah in the games the Vikings are
playing better than the other team Randy
Moss ends up with the ball 40 percent of
the time but if you force it to it you
ain't gonna win the game going to happen
so yes you will have a guy who rushes
for a hundred yards when you are kicking
the crap out of the other team but you
just don't give him the ball over and
over and over again and say oh we're
gonna were guaranteed to win the game if
we just give the ball to this guy
repeatedly
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports